[Music]
so hi my name is Ryan J Salva I am a
product manager on the visual studio
team I'm also a JavaScript developer of
about 15 years and a committer to the
Apache Cordova project today I'm gonna
take the next 30 minutes or so to talk
to you a little bit about performance
and a lot of the lessons that I talk
about today will apply to Cordova but
they apply equally well to the mobile
web and so really this is just gonna be
a a tour of a bunch of science that
we've conducted and I mean that like
science with a capital S really
important science to better understand
how exactly per Forks for mobile
applications when they're using web
technologies sound like a good time yeah
sounds like a good time awesome all
right sweet so hey if along this you
learn anything that you didn't know
before use the hash tag perf matters on
Twitter and share it with your friends
because science is everyone's awesome
thing to learn all right so like I said
before the lessons we learned today are
gonna apply equally well between hybrid
applications in mobile web and just a
kind of level set I want to make sure
that everyone understands when I talk
about hybrid applications what I'm
really talking about here so this is the
primary technology is Cordova most
people know what Cordova is or PhoneGap
yeah yeah yar okay good excellent so the
basic idea behind it is that Cordova its
core is a web application that sits
inside of a webview inside of a native
application and as a web application all
of the HTML the CSS and the JavaScript
are packaged locally but they kind of
talk back to native api's whether it be
the camera API or the address book or
the accelerometer through these
asynchronous calls that bridge the
webview and talk back to native code the
brilliant thing about this is that it
kind of gives you like a browser on
steroids you get access to all these
native api's that you wouldn't have
access to otherwise
and you get support for offline by
virtue of the fact that all of that HTML
CSS and JavaScript have been packaged
locally so that's the basic architecture
and we're gonna kind of use that to
explore like there's this perception
there's this general kind of ickiness
this feeling that web applications and
hybrid applications when compared to
native applications don't quite stand up
they don't really cut the butter as it
were and so in the next 30 minutes we're
gonna try and dispel some of those myths
using science all right to understand
performance you first need to understand
what it actually means to be fast and
responsive so here's what I want you
guys to do here's how I want you to
think about it I got a nice little graph
here and there's lots of different
flavors and versions of this graph that
you might have seen online I think I
stole this one from the Nielsen Norman
group and they probably created this
back in 1995 or something like that
but I've actually expanded it to put
some real millisecond measurements on
this so in the far left hand side that's
17 milliseconds everything that's under
fluid that's really not about user
interaction with your app but that's
about the way that your app moves
that's about animations being fluid
transitions kind of silky smooth flowing
through right and if you do the math
that 17 milliseconds actually calculates
out to be 60 frames per second that's
what that's about getting that magical
60 frames per second just to the right
of that instantaneous okay this is when
you're actually got your finger on the
mobile device you're dragging it around
and the object actually sticks to your
finger so this is really important to
make sure that like you actually feel
like you're in control of the
application beyond that actions which
are fast these are maybe like navigation
events going from one particular page to
the next loading a new view beyond that
everything to the right buddy if if
you've got something that takes that
long to react you better be throwing up
a spinner or something like that to let
people know that work is being done in
the background for this talk for the
next 20 30 minutes or so what
we care about is everything on that
right-hand side that far right-hand side
what we care about actually for you guys
wait that's left that's your left okay
our left-hand side from your left hand
side we care about fluid and
instantaneous because frankly everything
on the right hand side of that there's
no question that JavaScript CSS HTML are
capable of delivering that kind of
performance right so what is the
methodology behind our science so we
took a look at a bunch of different
applications and we and we kind of
looked at different approaches that
developers took to building out those
applications and we also took a look at
some of the major makers of the popular
UX frameworks that are out there so I'm
thinking of people here like ionic or
onsen or kendo and not the MV star
frameworks not the angular's of the
world of a reacts of the worlds but the
people that are making UX controls
because those are the things that end up
driving user interaction and we said you
know what is there any difference
between the way that average Joe
developer is building things today
versus the way that these people who are
creating the best-of-breed UX frameworks
are actually thinking about performance
and where there are differences between
the two what are the differences that
are contributing to poor performance
does that make sense
yeah and so from that we identified six
issues by the way the all of the tests
that we performed here because you need
to control four devices here we used
three kind of you know recent but not
too recent devices because we wanted to
find devices that were out there being
used by our mothers and our fathers and
our sisters and people that are not just
spending all of their time in the tech
world investing in the next greatest
thing right so they're slightly older
devices
so here the six different areas where we
found that there were discrepancies
between the way that the common
developer might go about building an
application and the kind of the best of
the back
so UX developers so webview tax document
object model images animation garbage
collection and UI controls these are the
areas where we found differences now
because I'm a sneaky guy I'm only going
to tell you about four of those today
really that's my way of tempting all of
you to come up and talk to me afterwards
so that you can find out the hidden
secrets behind animation and UI controls
we'll start by talking about these four
though sound good all right so the web
view tax now this first part this is
really specific to Cordova this is the
one piece of the talk that is only going
to apply to hybrid applications now as I
said before Cordova application has the
web application running inside of a
webview that's hosted inside of a native
control and because it kind of operates
inside of that webview there's a tax
that you got to pay and so here's what
we did first we said you know what let's
take a baseline let's measure the memory
footprint of a native application and
the native Java for Android objective-c
for iOS c-sharp for Windows and
Silverlight for Windows Phone right we
said okay if you were just to create a
hello world using the native language
what would the memory footprint being
and we said you know what I bet that
since a webview is essentially just a
browser that the memory footprint of a
Cordova app would probably be the native
application plus the memory footprint of
the browser and that would probably give
you the memory footprint of a Cordova
app and that could kind of give us an
idea of what the taxes that we pay there
so we did a measurement of a browser on
each of the devices so that's the memory
footprint of about blank in a web
browser on an Android phone and iOS
phone and Windows Device then we
measured the Cordova application now
there's some interesting things going on
here clearly androids got something
going on here there's like a World Trade
Center tower going up there
says the Cordova application has got
giant memory consumption problems on the
iOS side
well a plus B does not equal C they're
actually the memory footprint is about
the same as the browser Windows Store
glory be I don't even know how this is
possible but the memory footprint is
lower than the native app and lower than
the browser and then Windows Phone okay
it's kind of about the same now all
right so I want you all to remember that
giant Tower that's there next to Android
that's gonna come up later in some
interesting ways but just remember big
memory footprint on Android so here's
the thing it's lovely to talk about
memory but we're here to talk about
performance today and memory is not
something you can see where you can see
it has an effect is on startup time so
here's what we did took a slow motion
camera in this case I actually just used
my iPhone 6 it has a nice little slow
motion camera in it and filmed actually
starting up an application so hopefully
you can see this on the left-hand side
you can see us using a nice little touch
pin to click on the hello world app on
the right-hand side you can start to see
a little bit of ghosting where the
applications starting to launch we
measured the number of frames in between
the touch moment and the launch moment
because it was filmed at 240 frames per
second that meant that each frame
accounted for 4 milliseconds and we
could figure out how long it took to
actually launch the application ah now
remember how I asked you to remember
that giant kind of increase on the
Android side of things
look how tall or how long it took for
those Android Cordova apps to start up
so the memory and the startup time have
a strong correlation here on the iOS
side ok this tall pillar right here
that's the native app starting up I want
to put a little caveat next to that
that's why I put a little asterisk up at
the top we actually just used the
default hello world iOS app that came
out of Xcode the way that that app is
figured out of the box it has a 500
millisecond delay that is configurable
and so I believe that that number there
is actually a bit of a false
representation of what the actual native
implementation would would kind of cause
if we had adjusted that configuration
setting iOS is iOS warm is pretty good
when does phone cold is pretty good in
Windows Phone warm is pretty good these
cold versus warm so let me kind of give
a little bit of insight into the
methodology there cold means that we
shut the phone completely down then
started it up and then immediately
started the application warm means that
we shut the phone down turn it back on
started the application shut the
application down and then open the
application up again because each of the
devices makes some some sort of memory
optimizations for the cold horses warm
scenario we wanted to make sure that we
controlled for that depending upon the
actual usage so big takeaway here memory
consumption high correlation with slower
performance we're gonna see that theme
repeat again and again over the course
of the next 20 minutes so takeaway
Android tends to be slower and it tends
to be slower because we think because of
memory consumption all right there's one
more place that in a Cordova application
you're actually paying a tax and that's
in that xhr request that a synchronous
call that needs to go from the webview
to the native code and back again so
imagine for a moment that you are
sending a request for geolocation data
or for accelerometer data your web your
JavaScript needs to make the request at
asynchronous a synchronously crosses the
webview talks to the native code then
the native code needs to send that
response back with an XY and z
coordinate right so here's what we did
we created a cordova plugin whose only
job in this big wide world was just to
receive data and to
that data back it didn't perform any
processing on the data whatsoever it
just was there to measure the impact on
data size as it crossed over that web
view bridge and what we see here is a
nice linear line look at this
so for iOS Android and Windows Phone
using C sharp as the data increases
along the x-axis the time also increases
along the y-axis in a linear fashion
note however crossing the very bottom of
that line there's a kind of a yellow
line there that's windows phone using
javascript because windows devices are
able to run JavaScript as a native
language like you don't there's no
compilation that happens there
there's no webview to cross and so the
time to kind of interact with the
plug-in is zero no matter how large the
data set gets what I want to call your
attention to here though is that this
500k actually this is more than 500 K
this is 5,000 K in order for you to
transfer that over the webview is a
period of less than was that 300
milliseconds or so it's a very very
small amount of time and so even if you
were transferring a large amount of data
for example an image taken from a camera
it's going to happen in a practically
non noticeable period of time if you're
transferring smaller bits of data for
example accelerometer or geolocation
data it's going to be 2 3 4 milliseconds
very very tiny so what that tells us
that is that javascript in terms of
being able to deliver high performance
is able to really deliver right you
don't there's no waiting around for it
ok that's it for the Cordova specific
stuff now let's actually get into the
kind of the stuff that's applicable to
both Cordova and to mobile web so I
don't need to tell you guys too much
about what the DOM is you all know let's
see a dumb or rather an example here and
a bit about how this is going to
just to make sure that we had enough
time to show all the experiments what I
did is I did a screen recording of me
conducting these experiments when I
actually conduct them in the lab I'm
performing these experiments thousands
and thousands and thousands of times to
make sure that we get a good median and
a good baseline for each of them each
one of these is exemplary of those
thousands of runs ok so in this one I'm
going to conduct an experiment where I'm
performing Dom manipulation first using
a simple DOM and then using a complex
tone and what I mean by that a simple
Dom has fewer elements and no nesting
the complex Dom has very deep nesting
hundreds of nodes deep and multiple
elements for this I'm actually running
them on a nexus 9 that Nexus 9 this is
the case with all the experiments that
Nexus 9 is just being screencast to my
to my desktop via a fun little
application called mobizen all of the
experiments I'm going to show using
Android but the results tend to be
similar for iOS and Windows okay all
right for this I'm just gonna bring up
the chrome dev tools and the first one
that I'm gonna do is I'm going to
trigger manipulations of the simple Dom
and you can see here I'm just outputting
to the console the amount of time
required to perform each one of the
manipulations I've moved on to the
complex Dom using app in child then
complex Dom modifications using inner
HTML and then finally complex Dom
modifications using document fragment
right so everyone pretty much knows
those methods appendchild enter HTML
what I want to call your attention to is
the amount of time that it required to
perform a simple Dom manipulation versus
a complex Dom manipulation that's point
zero two six milliseconds compared to
point zero five four milliseconds now I
know I know I know
point zero two six milliseconds is just
not that much time
right it's it's nanoseconds right but
those will add up over time as your Dom
gets more and more complex and we're
actually gonna see that happen here in
just a minute so now we know surprise I
mean like this is almost common sense
simple Dom manipulations require less
time time than complex ones but that can
lead to some interesting choices about
how you write your code now like this is
all most unintelligent them whatever but
you're gonna make some different
decisions when you optimize for
performance versus optimizing for code
maintainability or code legibility in
this particular case I've reduced the
number of elements by 30% and by
reducing the number of elements as that
multiplies out over the broad scope of
an application that conservation of
elements is going to help me
tremendously so in this case it is
functionally equivalent but 30% fewer
actual Dom elements takeaway reduce your
element count all right so let's talk
about another little idiosyncrasy of Dom
manipulation and many of you may be
familiar with this kind of technique
before layout thrashing is basically
when you set a CSS property at the same
time as on the opposite side you're
reading the CSS property so let's see
how this actually works here right so I
got another video and in this particular
one you'll see that on the left hand
side I am setting my style to on the
right-hand side of the equal sign and
read a command so I'm just looping
through again and again and again
setting to a read in the second case and
this one I'm looping through I'm reading
all of the values first and then I have
a separate loop to set right now that
seems like a relatively small change and
again from a legibility or code
maintainability perspective it all
seems like the first is better so what
i'm doing here is first i'm going to
perform an action where it lets you know
that one i am using the thrashing so i'm
actually the very first one I read to my
set and in the second one I do the two
four loops now look at the comparison
here with thrashing that took nearly
four seconds without thrashing it took
only 56 milliseconds right that's a
eight fold improvement something like
that just by changing the order by which
we set and read so real quick here just
to reinforce it bad don't read it and
set it in the same line good read it
first set it later batch your layout
operations all the read at once all the
set at once okay let's talk about fast
list scrolling so this is essentially
when you've got thousands of elements on
a page and you need to be able to scroll
through them quickly in an infinite
scroll think here of something like I
don't know Facebook right where you're
just kind of scrolling forever and ever
and ever or Twitter or whatever your
favorite social media network is so in
this particular one in the first one I
am going to use just those I think it's
I think actually is a thousand elements
and I'm just gonna scroll through them
without any kind of optimizations
whatsoever it's just Dom elements on the
page iterating down in the second case
I'm going to use virtualization
virtualization is a technique where we
essentially simplify the Dom by removing
elements that are before and after the
visible screen so that there are less
elements on the page and remember back
before we had our lesson about when
there were fewer elements on the page
when we have a simple Dom it's the the
the actual browser is faster when we
have a complex Dom the browser tends to
be slower this is that same lesson
multiplied out in a way that you can
actually see it in a way that the user
would
so here we are we're actually launching
it up the in this particular case I just
got a little image of some fruit and
you'll see I'm kinda through here it
almost looks like the screen is
disappearing it's just going blank
that's not like a quirk of the video
that's because the elements the the
browser itself isn't able to keep up
with the paint and so they just
disappear as I quickly quickly quickly
move back and forth in it right and
sometimes they disappear for seconds at
a time so in this next one I'm actually
gonna launch it again and this time I'm
gonna use a virtualization so I'm only
keeping in memory elements that are one
or two maybe three screens before or
after the visible screen right in this
particular case I'm think what I was
using here was when Jay s is my
virtualization engine when Jay s happens
to have really good list scrolling but
there are lots of other frameworks that
provide virtualization for it alright
let's get it up here one of the other
things that I want you to know is here
is one of the other tricks of
virtualization is that as the as the
browser gets to a place where it no
longer has those elements in memory what
it will start to do you see those gray
gray boxes essentially what it's doing
is putting in dummy elements so that you
feel like the the application is able to
keep up with it think here I'll use
Facebook again as an example when you
first load facebook on your mobile phone
it's got a couple of placeholder kind of
posts in there same idea this is really
all about of improving the perception of
performance and when we measure this out
we actually measured the memory of these
guys the virtualized list
less than a hundred megabytes of memory
for that particular application at
runtime the non-virtualized list over
was that nearly three hundred and fifty
megabytes and again we see a strong
correlation between the memory
consumption and the actual performance
itself and so any time that you find
yourself in a position where you're
trying to measure for performance and
trying to optimize for
formants measuring frames per second
great you should do that but as a proxy
it can sometimes be helpful to also look
at your memory consumption as well all
right take away use virtualization when
you can
lots of frameworks do it my advice don't
try to do this yourself writing
virtualization is hard it's super hard
just use another framework ok images so
here's a funny one this is like
completely this this blows my mind when
I see this one it's it's totally weird
so I didn't know how long have CSS
Graydon's gradients been around this is
like can anyone remember 2008 I don't
know something like that CSS gradients
are super super helpful they allow us to
be a little bit more responsive in our
design it we don't have to cut like a
one by one
you know pixel tile to kind of grayed
across but just like before when we were
looking at how we might reduce our
overall element count there are
different decisions that you might make
when you're optimizing for performance
versus when you're maintaining for or
when you're writing for code
maintainability so in this particular
case I've got two objects the first
object just uses a regular old CSS
gradient the second object uses a PNG
file to create my gradient alright what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna animate these
guys and when I animate these guys I'm
gonna use the chrome dev tools to
measure frames per second and I hope
that many of you are familiar with the
chrome dev tools performance
optimization tools if you're not the
quick rule here is that tall bars up
there or bad low bars are good right so
in the first case where you see all
those giant green skyscrapers that's
what I'm animating the CSS gradient on
the right hand side when I'm animating
the image all those low bars that's when
I'm animating the bitmapped ping like
what what's up with that
like seriously what's up with that so
here's what I think is actually
happening right and I like here
actually you no need to call my friends
over at Google and verify this but
here's what I think is happening when
you animate that CSS gradient every time
it moves a frame over it needs to redraw
the gradient each time when it's
animating the bitmap or the ping in this
particular case that already exists it
doesn't need to redraw it every time and
so you get better animation when you're
moving the already in memory image
compared to what's essentially creating
an image for each for each frame of the
CSS and so if there's a kind of a a bad
version of this again like can't believe
I'm putting this up there bad CSS
gradients but somehow that is the case
when you're optimizing for performance
versus blow your mind good why in the
world is this but it once again when
you're optimizing for performance you're
going to make different decisions than
you would otherwise
all right so use images Oh garbage
collection everybody loves the garbage
collector he takes all of our dirty
memory away so garbage collectors have
been around for you know since browsers
were around and and generally they're
pretty efficient but when you're dealing
with a mobile application and I would
say that this is particularly poignant
for hybrid applications where the app
itself is going to be a single page
application that rarely shuts down
memory management becomes really really
important and that garbage collector it
does run automatically but you can get
yourself into a bad spot where it's um
it's it's unable to do its job so here's
what we're gonna do I want to kind of
show this in action and in this
particular one hit play here what I'm
going to do is I'm going to create a
bunch of elements and I'm going to
attach event handlers to those elements
just in the loops you see there add
event listener and then I'm just going
to destroy them by saying enter HTML
equals to blank what that means is that
as I destroy those my event handler is
still sticking around in memory and the
garbage collector has a
really tough time getting back to it so
what I'm gonna do here is I'm gonna
start running this guy and once again in
our friend chrome dev tools I want you
to notice once I start running it
there's gonna be a ramp that blue ramp
that starts to get bigger and bigger and
bigger bigger again that is death that
is death for your application over time
as memory just balloons out of scale now
granted here I am creating thousands and
thousands and thousands over again right
and you might think to yourself well and
my web application
I'm never gonna be creating these
thousands of elements again and again
and again but but you actually you are
especially if you've got a single page
application that guy could stay open for
a long time you may never shut it down
for months and as the memory grows and
those event handlers stick around behind
you're basically just signing up for a
browser crash at some point so bad here
eventlistener
still hanging around even after we
destroyed our element good be
responsible boys and girls destroy your
event handlers right remove event hit
event listener right there then
responsibly remove your child all right
now while we're on the subject of event
listeners let's talk about how we can
actually not just irresponsible create
and destroy them but also how we can
minimize the total number of them now I
don't know about you guys but um I often
like I go out I do a query selector all
or a dollar sign dollar sign I go get a
big collection of elements that loop
through them and as I loop through them
I just add in an event handler teach one
on click event handler on click event
handler and what that ends up doing is
that ends up creating a rubber-stamp
duplicate of every function again and
again and again and again and that
multiplicity that that giant collection
of
handlers are once again just consuming
more memory and so what I want you to to
encourage you to do here is rather than
create an event listener or event
handler for each element instead think
about using a single event handler for
all of your objects within a node tree
let me let me kind of explain what I
mean here a little bit so one two three
four and five those little elements down
at the bottom they've all got a common
ancestor in this case the dude right so
that dude through the magic of event
bubbling receives all the same events
that one two three four and five receive
so what I want to encourage you to do is
think about how you can use event
handlers or event listeners on the dude
to respond to events that occur on its
children so here's what we're gonna do
we're actually show this in action so
I'm gonna have a couple of different
scenarios here in scenario one I'm going
to have one event handler for each
element in scenario two I'm going to use
event bubbling and then attach a
essentially a switch case to my event
handler to say what did you click on
oh you clicked on ancestor or rather
child a then do this and then in case
three I'm going to have that same kind
of one-to-one relationship between event
listeners and objects but this time I'm
going to use a common function for all
of them so here's what I've done I've
just executed the first of those
scenarios that is one event handler per
element and I've taken a little snapshot
of memory now I'm executing scenario two
this is the one with event bubbling
where we use a switch case on the top
level element to identify the actual
element that it was clicked upon and
then okay we're taking that snap shot
now and now snap shot three where we
actually have an event listener for
every element
but it all points to the same common
eventhandler the same common function
what I want to point to in this we're
gonna kind of drag it around here I want
you to take a look at the retained size
that's that far column right there so
look at that 257 K or 8% of the total
memory is dedicated to the Dom okay
snapshot - this is the one where we use
the one-to-one relationship oh man that
was 468 K and then snapshot one this is
the one oh that's that that's the bad
one right that's one two one one event
handler per object and here we can see
I'm actually gonna open it up and you'll
be able to see one event handler per
object there there it is that native
function right there that's one per
object and then in snapshots one and
three those are the ones where I've got
a common event handler for each element
right through that I realize what's here
I'll rewind it a bit so you can see it
mmm there we are the 257 there right it
is about half of the retained memory
size when I use either a common event
handler for each event listener or I do
the handler on the parent element when
this this it's helpful if you see a
quick little code example here right so
for this one bad
I'm just doing a loop I'm attaching a
single an event handler to each object
and each of those event handlers is
essentially a clone of the one before it
whereas good I'm attaching an event
listener to the parent and in this case
I just use an if statement I could be a
little bit more sophisticated use a
switch statement to figure out which
child I clicked on again that resulted
in about half of the retained memory
size a win not only for memory but also
for your performance so take advantage
of event bubbling
pay attention to memory leaks
okay memory leaks so this is kind of a
variation of what we saw earlier with
the event that we left kind of hanging
on right where we created a lot of
elements destroy them and left an event
handler sticking around so in this
particular one what I'm going to do what
I'm going to do is I'm going to cycle
through and create a bunch of elements
and then for those elements I'm going to
keep each one of the elements scoped to
the private function right and this
first time around because it's scoped to
the private function those functions and
those objects will will will be
destroyed when the function itself is
destroyed and so here we're gonna launch
it up there we go here it comes
little heap snapshot there alright and
so as I'm navigating from page to page
what it's essentially doing is creating
those objects destroying those objects
creating those objects destroying those
objects right and as it does so because
the objects are created as part of the
private function the objects are
destroyed with a lifetime of the
function itself and so here what I want
you to see look it's a nice clean Dom
here there are no unparent 'add div
elements those are all white white is
good you like white all right now what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna switch it up a
little bit this time just by removing
the VAR declaration from within the
function scope I'm immediately putting
each one of the div elements into the
global scope because they are in the
global scope they are not destroyed when
you destroy the function as well and so
those will end up hanging around as
unparent ated Dom fragments sticking
around in my application so here we go
we're gonna do the navigation again I'm
gonna fast forward just a little bit
there we go
navigate back and forth once again
creating destroying each of the
functions but this time because all of
my elements are being created in the
global scope when I create an destroy my
functions my objects are still sticking
around my Dom objects are still sticking
around all right let the snapshot do its
computational powers and when we expose
this look at all of that read each one
of those objects that's marked as kind
of with a pinkish red background these
are objects that are just polluting your
Dom taking up space taking up memory and
dragging you down right so a good kind
of check for yourself is run your
application for a little while go back
into chrome dev tools see if you can
find into these objects that are red and
try and find out where those get created
how you can destroy them because over
time they're just going to increase your
overall memory footprint and ultimately
drag down your performance as well so
bad in this particular case we've got
the element created in the global scope
outside of the function good we're
actually creating the element within the
scope of the function and so it gets
destroyed with the function destroy all
your unused objects so we're getting to
the end of it
I beg beg of you if you remember
anything about this talk anyone can
build slow apps you can you can that guy
has I know he has back there you can do
it too
anyone can build slow apps but you don't
have to like go into it thinking about
performance first before it drags you
down in the end thank you so much once
again Ryan J Salva come talk to me
afterwards I'd love to talk to you about
animation and UI controls and all the
experiments that I didn't get to share
with you today thank you so much thank
you
you
[Music]
[Music]